[Music]
[Music]
what would my advice be to a driven and
intelligent college student or young
person about to enter the real world
well I would be very simple it would be
focus on learning instead of earning and
that sounds cliched but I'll explain why
because if you want to make say a
million dollars a year ten million
dollars a year instead of a hundred
thousand dollars a year I would argue
you probably don't want to take the
hundred thousand dollar per year job
even if it's offered to you right out of
the gate that sounds like a lot of money
but what I'm going to recommend is not
limited to finances you want to focus on
projects on companies on environments
where you can learn lessons on someone
else's bankroll alright so let them pay
for it and view it effectively as an
apprenticeship so find a situation where
you can be in the room with masters of a
craft and that could just be deal making
it could be joining a small company say
a fewer than 50 people where you simply
get to observe one of the principles
negotiating in an industry that you
don't even care anything about right it
could be waste management and you want
to go into high tech but if you sit in a
room with someone who's an absolute pro
at crafting deals negotiating getting
past know those skills and maybe those
relationships start to snowball all
right and this is what scott adams the
creator and Dilbert would call systems
thinking's instead of being wedded to
the outcome of a given job you are
accumulating skills and relationships
that transcend that job okay and if you
choose your environments well because as
I've said before and as people like drew
the CEO of Dropbox as a friend have said
you're the average of the five people
you associate with most all right so if
you take just a few years have the
patience a few years to really develop
core competencies that allow you to
craft your own reality and life
negotiation deal-making getting past
know etc learning how to pitch how to
get someone's attention in 30 seconds so
that you can then create the desire and
ultimately ask for some type of action
once you develop those then you can
really just create the map for the next
decade in the next several decades so
that would be it it would be learn
before you earn and it's never too late
to do that so I don't care if you're
coming out of college coming out of high
school
30 40 whatever it is Systems thinking
focus on the skills and relationships
first and then you can just create a
blank check for how much money you want
to make if that is your goal hey guys if
you're enjoying the tips and tactics and
how-to on this channel or in the podcast
the Tim Ferriss show I made this for you
try the mentors short advice from the
best in the world this is the book that
I wanted to read so I went out and I put
it together created a dream list of a
hundred and thirty of the best at what
they do people who are icons legends and
asked them all the same questions these
are people in some cases I wanted to
reach out to my whole life ranges from
many many billionaires cofounders of
every company imaginable elite athletes
ranging from surfing to tennis to
powerlifting everything else country
stars actors directors and you can spot
the pattern so some of my friends have
said this is the easiest to read most
useful book that I've put together yet
so check it out tribe of mentors dot-com
you can find sample chapters the whole
list of mentors everything tribe mentors
calm